[Music]
you know one of the trends on tick tock
for some reason is for people to post
videos documenting and explaining their
morning routines the thing that you
quickly notice if you watch a few of
these videos is that people on tick tock
perhaps unsurprisingly have a lot of
free time on their hands so for their
morning routines they wake up at a
leisurely hour they do 45 minutes of
yoga an hour of meditation they go into
their immaculate remodeled kitchen with
top of the line appliances that they
could somehow afford just by not having
a job they make some kind of green
healthy smoothie go for a jog do some
crunches
then they go consult their personal guru
who lives on a goat farm at the top of a
mountain then they have lunch and it's
all quite difficult to relate to
especially as a parent i mean my
feelings about yoga are well known but
even if i was inclined to give yoga a
shot i don't think my kids would stay
out of my hair long enough for me to get
a good yoga session in or whatever you
call it though they probably would enjoy
coming with me to the mountaintop goat
farm come to think of it in any case we
know that um
this is the kind of thing it's one it's
one of the the two main genres of
content on social media especially on
sites like tik tok and instagram this is
the
my life is perfect
look how happy and put together i am
genre
the second genre is the exact opposite
of that
it is in fact meant to be a correction
to the first type though it ends up
being just as bad if not considerably
worse and that is the my life is
terrible look how miserable i am please
feel sorry for me genre
so one tick tock or a lawyer in toronto
has made her own morning routine video
which fits into this latter category uh
she's been applauded for this video
which has been viewed many millions of
times buzzfeed says that it's refreshing
and makes them feel seen
upworthy agrees that it's refreshing and
honest yahoo celebrates it for being
authentic and real
in the video the 27 year old woman shows
us what her routine is like as a lawyer
who is depressed as f watch
this is my very realistic non-aesthetic
morning routine as a lawyer who was
depressed as
took me half an hour to get out of bed
so i was very late this morning i admit
i washed my face to wake up but didn't
brush my teeth too lazy for a base
routine so i just mix some foundation
with moisturizer my latte also exploded
in the microwave very on brand i have to
contour my face to hide the fact that
it's so bloated from drinking last night
i'm really not doing well please don't
judge me i can't bring myself to give
any more than i do so putting my hair up
millennial style okay none of that clean
girl slicked back bun
honestly though i don't care how
depressed i am i will not wear my hair
in a ponytail like that i put on some
earrings though good for me
i'm wearing crocs to work because i'm
sad please don't ask me why there's
tupperware on the floor okay have a nice
day
well that was
important information clearly and too uh
too depressed and sad to put the effort
in to
brush your teeth but you can put the
effort in to make a video and edit it
and post it
now the comments are all raving about
this they call the video beautiful and
raw and vulnerable important and amazing
the lady simply just announced that she
didn't brush her teeth in the morning
and these people want to
award her the middle of freedom for it
and why well because it validates their
own laziness and recasts their own
self-centered disregard as somehow brave
and empowered so let's consider a few
points related to all this
first
brush your teeth that's disgusting
second anytime you put personal
information on the internet and demand
not to be judged for it
you're lying because you do want to be
judged you wouldn't publish it for the
world to see if you didn't want the
world to make a judgment about it if you
really didn't want to be judged at all
for the fact that you're practicing poor
hygiene you just wouldn't tell anybody
and nobody would know unless they end up
stuck in an elevator next to you
you take the time to record and publish
the video because you want to hear the
public's opinion it's just that you
expect that the public will have a
positive affirming opinion that's what
you're really asking for it's not don't
judge me it's rather judge me in a nice
and encouraging way
but that demand is unfair and also
impossible i mean once you tell me
something about yourself that i didn't
ask for or want to know
you've given me information that my mind
will process however it wants to process
it that's not my fault
you can't give me unsolicited
information and also assign me an
opinion that i'm supposed to have about
that information that's not how it works
second you know we've all had times when
we feel especially down
and completing normal basic tasks feels
like a huge burden
but those are precisely the times when
it's most important that you complete
the tasks and you do the chores and you
follow the routine
if you wake up feeling extra depressed
you should be even
putting even more effort into your
mundane tasks you should try to look
even sharper and more put together than
usual the point is not to suppress your
feelings exactly but rather to refuse to
become a slave to them
fake it till you make it it's one of the
most fundamental truths of human nature
it may not be a catch-all cure for
depression i'm not saying that it is but
there are certainly worse treatment
plans on the market tell you that much
now if you allow your feelings to
entirely dictate your behavior
and you use them to justify slacking off
not taking care of yourself not taking
care of your responsibilities
soon you'll be caught in this
self-defeating spiral that becomes
harder and harder to escape from
not brushing your teeth in the morning
is the first step towards that spiral
but it gets you closer to the spiral
than you might think
after all brushing your teeth is a very
low effort task that anyone can complete
i don't care how depressed you are
you let your feelings justify skipping
that step and soon they'll be justifying
much more than that
third point finally
you know i get as annoyed as anyone by
the my life is perfect genre of social
media posts
but i'll take that over the my life is a
mess genre any day
the former may be cherry-picked and
largely fake but at least it's
aspirational
you know i'm never going to be somebody
who drinks healthy green smoothies every
morning or any morning but i'd rather
hear about that
than have you tell me about your diet
that's even more disgusting and lazier
than my diet
there's a very dangerous inclination in
all humans to take comfort in the fact
that other people have personal habits
and engage in behaviors that are worse
than our own
that's why the my life is miserable
genre is pretty popular people are
looking for ways to rationalize their
worst tendencies
they want to be able to point at
somebody and say man i felt kind of bad
about myself but it turns out that this
person behaves the same way and even
worse actually so i guess i'm not so bad
off
one of the most popular mental health
slogans these days is um
that i'm sure you've heard before is
it's okay to be not okay
but i can't think of a worse thing to
say to someone who isn't okay
it's not okay to be not okay that's why
we call it not okay
you might as well say it's happy to be
sad or it's comfortable to be in pain
you should try to be okay rather than
not okay you shouldn't simply resign
yourself to being not okay you should
aim up
this is one of the reasons why i despise
all the efforts to so-called normalized
depression the effect is that is that
now it's become an identity it's become
a lifestyle
rather than something that you strive to
overcome and conquer
because nobody's aiming up anymore
they keep their vision fixed parallel to
the floor
and they stay on whatever level they're
currently on
or else they intentionally aim down
no don't do that aim up put in the
effort
try to be better
help yourself
brush your teeth
that's my message to the depressed
lawyer on tick tock listen hit that
subscribe button right now do it right
now i thank you for your compliance it
is
somewhat appreciated